I left out a step that happens after projection and before division by W.
Clipping. Say we have 2 points: 0, 4, negative 6 after perspective
transformation that turns into 0, 4, 5, 6 and 0, 6, negative 4, which turns
into this value. They form a line segment. These two points in this line
segment are shown on this zoomed in part of our frustum. The second point is
outside of the frustum. We want to have all coordinates inside our final view
volume in NDC space so that we can render them. Clipping is done for line
segments and triangle edges that poke out through the frustum. An edge can be
clipped by any numbers of faces of the frustum. What happens here is that all
the coordinates between the two points get linearly interpolated. For our
example the point on the frustum faces halfway between our two points. The
interpolated point is then 0, 5, 3.85. We then divide this point by W as usual
to get a point in normalized device coordinates. Here's a rough overview of how
clipping can work. You start with a triangle that's poking out through the
frustum. Say the left face of the frustum first cuts the triangle. This creates
two triangles. Later, the top face of the frustum chops off the other part of
the triangle. This create three triangles total that will then be rasterized
separately by the GPU. You as a user don't really have to know or care much
about this clipping process. It happens automatically. It's worth knowing about
mostly if you need to do similar testing operations on the CPU side. In
computer graphics we often make a big deal about how we store 3D points in
vectors as homogeneous coordinates, with the fourth element W. In reality, for
almost every operation, the W value is either 0, meaning a vector, or 1,
meaning a point. It's only after projection and during clipping that the W
value is anything but 1. Once clipping is done and we're using normalized
device coordinates, we're done with homogeneous coordinates. However, these
homogeneous coordinates are important in that they're what the vertex shader
produces. When the coordinate is transformed by the projection matrix, but
before the division is performed, the coordinates are called clip coordinates.
The vertex shader can produce other intermediate results, such as computing
location once the model and view matrices are applied. It is required that the
vertex shader produce a position on the screen for the vertex. This position is
a homogeneous coordinate. The rasterizer then takes this position and performs
clipping.